[Music]
[Applause]
these mascots should not dunk first up
it's a mascot that really shouldn't the
container of non-dairy creamer
and go go
[Applause]
creamer mixed with asbestos all right
this mascot should really never dunk
it's the after christmas cd bargain bin
get him out yeah
go bergen bin go
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
i'm sorry
thank you yeah
it's
it's seeing them struggle to get up it's
so sad
all right up next i don't know if this
has ever happened in the wild i hope it
does it's the bear being attacked by
sharks
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't know i yes think of a scenario
where that happens
[Laughter]
he's covered in non-dairy he's really
handling it quite well he's handling it
very well next up a medieval hero who
never lasts very long in battle please
welcome the pumpkin knight let's get the
pumpkin night out here
terrible idea go pumpkin night go
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the worst idea for armor ever yeah yeah
all right next up the uh the uh the next
star wars movie won't be out until 2015
but that doesn't trouble our next mascot
that's right it's the star wars nerd
who's already camping out online for
tickets
[Applause]
that nerd's ready to go and go nerd go
come on
nerd yes
that's fantastic yeah
and finally last up an all-you-can-eat
favorite for people who've never had
authentic italian cuisine the olive
garden never ending possible
go possible go
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
why
on so many levels why all right let's
hear it the ncaa mascot said should
never dump